The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: In discussing
the continuous-time and
discrete-time Fourier
transforms, we developed a
number of important
properties.
Two particularly significant
ones, as I mentioned at the
time, are the modulation
property and
the convolution property.
Starting with the next lecture,
the one after this
one, we'll be developing and
exploiting some of the
consequences of the modulation
property.
In today's lecture though, I'd
like to review and expand on
the notion of filtering, which,
as I had mentioned,
flows more or less directly from
the convolution property.
To begin, let me just quickly
review what the convolution
property is.
Both for continuous-time and
for discrete-time, the
convolution property tells us
that the Fourier transform of
the convolution of two time
functions is the product of
the Fourier transforms.
Now, what this means in terms
of linear time-invariant
filters, since we know that in
the time domain the output of
a linear time-invariant filter
is the convolution of the
input and the impulse response,
it says essentially
then in the frequency domain
that the Fourier transform of
the output is the product the
Fourier transform of the
impulse response, namely the
frequency response, and the
Fourier transform
of the input.
So the output is described
through that product.
Now, recall also that in
developing the Fourier
transform, I interpreted the
Fourier transform as the
complex amplitude of a
decomposition of the signal in
terms of a set of complex
exponentials.
And the frequency response or
the convolution property, in
effect, tells us how to modify
the amplitudes of each of
those complex exponentials as
they go through the system.
Now, this led to the notion of
filtering, where the basic
concept was that since we can
modify the amplitudes of each
of the complex exponential
components separately, we can,
for example, retain
some of them and
totally eliminate others.
And this is the basic
notion of filtering.
So we have, as you recall, first
of all the notion in
continuous-time of an ideal
filter, for example, I
illustrate here an ideal lowpass
filter where we pass
exactly frequency components in
one band and reject totally
frequency components
in another band.
The band being passed, of
course, referred to as the
passband, and the band rejected
as the stopband.
I illustrated here
a lowpass filter.
We can, of course, reject the
low frequencies and retain the
high frequencies.
And that then corresponds to
an ideal highpass filter.
Or we can just retain
frequencies within a band.
And so I show below what is
referred to commonly as a
bandpass filter.
Now, this is what the ideal
filters looked like for
continuous-time.
For discrete-time, we have
exactly the same situation.
Namely, we have an ideal
discrete-time lowpass filter,
which passes exactly frequencies
which are the low
frequencies.
Low frequencies, of course,
being around 0, and because of
the periodicity, also
around 2pi.
We show also an ideal
highpass filter.
And a highpass filter, as I
indicated last time, passes
frequencies around pi.
And finally, below that, I show
an ideal bandpass filter
passing frequencies someplace in
the range between 0 and pi.
And recall also that the basic
difference between
continuous-time a discrete-time
for these
filters is that the
discrete-time versions are, of
course, periodic in frequency.
Now, let's look at these ideal
filters, and in particular the
ideal lowpass filter
in the time domain.
We have the frequency response
of the ideal lowpass filter.
And shown below it is the
impulse response.
So here is the frequency
response and below it the
impulse response of the
ideal lowpass filter.
And this, of course,
is a sine x over x
form of impulse response.
And recognize also or recall
that since this frequency
response is real-valued, the
impulse response, in other
words, the inverse transform is
an even function of time.
And notice also, since I want
to refer back to this, that
the impulse response of an ideal
lowpass filter, in fact,
is non-causal.
That follows, from among other
things, from the fact that
it's an even function.
But keep in mind, in fact, that
a sine x over x function
goes off to infinity
in both directions.
So the impulse response of the
ideal lowpass filter is
symmetric and continues to have
tails off to plus and
minus infinity.
Now, the situation is basically
the same in the
discrete-time case.
Let's look at the frequency
response and associated
impulse response for an ideal
discrete-time lowpass filter.
So once again, here is the
frequency response of the
ideal lowpass filter.
And below what I show the
impulse response.
Again, it's a sine x over x
type of impulse response.
And again, we recognize that
since in the frequency domain,
this frequency response
is real-valued.
That means, as a consequence
of the properties of the
Fourier transform and inverse
Fourier transform, that the
impulse response is an even
function in the time domain.
And also, incidentally, the sine
x over x function goes
off to infinity, again,
in both directions.
Now, we've talked about ideal
filters in this discussion.
And ideal filters all
are, in fact, ideal
in a certain sense.
What they do ideally is they
pass a certain band of
frequencies exactly and
they reject a band
of frequencies exactly.
On the other hand, there are
many filtering problems in
which, generally, we don't
have a sharp distinction
between the frequencies we
want to pass and the
frequencies we want to reject.
One example of this that's
elaborated on in the text is
the design of an automotive
suspension system, which, in
fact, is the design of
a lowpass filter.
And basically what you want to
do in a case like that is
filter out or attenuate very
rapid road variations and keep
the lower variations in, of
course, elevation of the
highway or road.
And what you can see intuitively
is that there
isn't really a very sharp
distinction or sharp cut-off
between what you would logically
call the low
frequencies and what you would
call the high frequencies.
Now, also somewhat related to
this is the fact that as we've
seen in the time domain, these
ideal filters have a very
particular kind of character.
For example, let's look back at
the ideal lowpass filter.
And we saw the impulse
response.
The impulse response is what
we had shown here.
Let's now look at the step
response of the discrete-time
ideal lowpass filter.
And notice the fact that it has
a tail that oscillates.
And when the step hits,
in fact, it has
an oscillatory behavior.
Now, exactly the same
situation occurs in
continuous-time.
Let's look at the step
response of the
continuous-time ideal
lowpass filter.
And what we see is that when a
step hits then, in fact, we
get an oscillation.
And very often, that oscillation
is something
that's undesirable.
For example, if you were
designing an automotive
suspension system and you hit
a curve, which is a step
input, in fact, you probably
would not like to have the
automobile oscillating, dying
down in oscillation.
Now there's another very
important point, which again,
we can see either in
continuous-time or
discrete-time, which is that
even if we want it to have an
ideal filter, the ideal filter
has another problem if we want
to attempt to implement
it in real time.
What's the problem?
The problem is that since the
impulse response is even and,
in fact, has tails that go off
to plus and minus infinity,
it's non-causal.
So if, in fact, we want to build
a filter and the filter
is restricted to operate in real
time, then, in fact, we
can't build an ideal filter.
So what that says is that, in
practice, although ideal
filters are nice to think about
and perhaps relate to
practical problems, more
typically what we consider are
nonideal filters and in the
discrete-time case, a nonideal
filter then we would have a
characteristic somewhat like
I've indicated here.
Where instead of a very rapid
transition from passband to
stopband, there would be a more
gradual transition with a
passband cutoff frequency and
a stopband cutoff frequency.
And perhaps also instead of
having an exactly flat
characteristic in the stopband
in the passband, we would
allow a certain amount
of ripple.
We also have exactly the same
situation in continuous-time,
where here we'll just simply
change our frequency axis to a
continuous frequency axis
instead of the discrete
frequency axis.
Again, we would think in terms
of an allowable passband
ripple, a transition from
passband to stopband with a
passband cutoff frequency and
a stopband cutoff frequency.
So the notion here is that,
again, ideal filters are ideal
in some respects, not ideal
in other respects.
And for many practical
problems, we
may not want them.
And even if we did want them,
we may not be able to get
them, perhaps because of this
issue of causality.
Even if causality is not an
issue, what happens in filter
design and implementation, in
fact, is that the sharper you
attempt to make the cutoff, the
more expensive, in some
sense, the filter becomes,
either in terms of components,
in continuous-time, or in
terms of computation in
discrete-time.
And so there are these whole
variety of issues that really
make it important to
understand the
notion nonideal filters.
Now, just to illustrate as an
example, let me remind you of
one example of what, in fact, is
a nonideal lowpass filter.
And we have looked previously
at the associated
differential equation.
Let me now, in fact, relate
it to a circuit, and in
particular an RC circuit, where
the output could either
be across the capacitor
or the output can
be across the resistor.
So in effect, we have
two systems here.
We have a system, which is the
system function from the
voltage source input to the
capacitor output, the system
from the voltage source input
to the resistor output.
And, in fact, just applying
Kirchhoff's Voltage Law to
this, we can relate those in
a very straightforward way.
It's very straightforward to
verify that the system from
input to resistor output is
simply the identity system
with the capacitor output
subtracted from it.
Now, we can write the
differential equation for
either of these systems and, as
we talked about last time
in the last several lectures,
solve that equation using and
exploiting the properties of
the Fourier transform.
And in fact, if we look at the
differential equation relating
the capacitor output to the
voltage source input, we
recognize that this is an
example that, in effect, we've
solved previously.
And so just working our way
down, applying the Fourier
transform to the differential
equation and generating the
system function by taking the
ratio of the capacitor voltage
or its Fourier transform to the
Fourier transform of the
source, we then have the system
function associated
with the system for which
the output is
the capacitor voltage.
Or if we solve instead for the
system function associated
with the resistor output,
we can simply
subtract H1 from unity.
And the system function that
we get in that case is the
system function that
I show here.
So we have, now, two system
functions, one for the
capacitor output, the other
for the resistor output.
And one, the first,
corresponding to the capacitor
output, in fact, if we plot it
on a linear amplitude scale,
looks like this.
And as you can see, and as
we saw last time, is an
approximation to a
lowpass filter.
It is, in fact, and nonideal
lowpass filter, whereas the
resistor output is an
approximation to a highpass
filter, or in effect, a nonideal
highpass filter.
So in one case, just comparing
the two, we have a lowpass
filter as the capacitor output
associated with the capacitor
output, and a highpass filter
associated with
the resistor output.
Let's just quickly look at that
example now, looking on a
Bode plot, instead of
on the linear scale
that we showed before.
And recall incidentally, and be
aware incidentally, of the
fact that we can, of course,
cascade several filters of
this type and improve
the characteristics.
So I have shown at the top
a Bode plot of the system
function associated with
the capacitor output.
It's flat out to a frequency
corresponding to 1 over the
time constant, RC.
And then it falls off at 10 dB
per decade, a decade being a
factor of 10.
Or if instead we look at the
system function associated
with the resistor output, that
corresponds to a 10 dB per
decade increase in frequency
up to approximately the
reciprocal of the time constant,
and then approaching
a flat characteristic
after that.
And if we consider either one
of these, looking back again
at the lowpass filter, if we
were to cascade several
filters with this frequency
response, then because we have
things plotted on a Bode plot,
the Bode plot for the cascade
would simply be summing these.
And so if we cascaded, for
example, two stages instead of
a roll-off at 10 dB per decade,
it would roll off at
20 dB per decade.
Now, filters in this type, RC
filters, perhaps several of
them in cascade, are in
fact very prevalent.
And in fact, in an environment
like this, where we're, in
fact, doing recording, we see
there are filters of that type
that show up very commonly
both in the audio and the
video portion of the signal
processing that's associated
with making this set of tapes.
In fact, let's take a look
in the control room.
And what I'll be able to show
you in the control room is the
audio portion of the processing
that's done and the
kinds of filters, very much of
the type we just talked about,
that are associated with the
signal processing that's done
in preparing the audio
for the tapes.
So let's just take a walk
into the control room
and see what we see.
This is the control room that's
used for camera switching.
It's used for computer editing
and also audio control.
You can see the monitors,
and these are used
for the camera switching.
And this is the computer editing
console that's used
for online and offline
computer editing.
What I really want to
demonstrate though, in the
context of the lecture is the
audio control panel, which
contains, among other things, a
variety of filters for high
frequency, low frequencies,
et cetera, basically
equalization filters.
And what we have in the way of
filtering is, first of all,
what's referred to as a graphic
equalizer, which
consists of a set of bandpass
filters, which I'll describe a
little more carefully
in a minute.
And then also, an audio control
panel, which is down
here and which contains separate
equalizer circuits
for each of a whole set of
channels and also lots of
controls on them.
Well, let me begin in the
demonstration by demonstrating
a little bit of what the
graphic equalizer does.
Well, what we have is a set
of bandpass filters.
And what's indicated up here are
the center frequencies of
the filters, and then a slider
switch for each one that lets
us attenuate or amplify.
And this is a dB scale.
So essentially, if you look
across this bank of filters
with the total output of the
equalizer just being the sum
of the outputs from each of
these filters, interestingly
the position of the slider
switches as you move across
here, in effect, shows you what
the frequency response of
the equalizer is.
So you can change the overall
shaping of the filter by
moving the switches
up and down.
Right now the equalizer
is out.
Let's put the equalizer
into the circuit.
And now I put in this filtering
characteristic.
And what I'd like to demonstrate
is filtering with
this, when we do things that
are a little more dramatic
than what would normally be
done in a typical audio
recording setting.
And to do this, let's add to my
voice some music to make it
more interesting.
Not that my voice isn't
interesting as it is.
But in any case, let's
bring some music up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And now what I'll do is set
the low frequencies flat.
And let me take out the high
frequencies above 800 cycles.
And so now what we have,
effectively,
is a lowpass filter.
And now with the lowpass filter,
let me now bring the
highs back up.
And so I'm bringing up those
bandpass filters.
And now let me cut
out the lows.
And you'll hear the lows
disappearing and, in effect,
keeping the highs in effectively
crispens the
sound, either my voice
or the music.
And finally, let me go back to
0 dB equalization on each of
the filters.
And what I'll also do now is
take the equalizer out of the
circuit totally.
Now, let's take a look at the
audio master control panel.
And this panel has, of course,
for each channel and, for
example, the channel
that we're working
on, of a volume control.
I can turn the volume down, and
I can turn the volume up.
And it also has, for this
particular equalizer circuit,
it has a set of three bandpass
filters and knobs which let us
either put in up to 12 dB gain
or 12 dB attenuation in each
of the bands, and also a
selector switch that lets us
select the center the band.
So let me just again
demonstrate a
little bit with this.
And let's get a close
up of this panel.
So what we have, as
I indicated, is
three bandpass filters.
And these knobs that I'm
pointing to here are controls
that allow us for each of the
filters to put in up to 12 dB
gain or 12 dB attenuation.
There are also with each of the
filters a selector switch
that lets us adjust the center
frequency of the filter.
Basically it's a two-position
switch.
There also, as you can see, is
a button that let's us either
put the equalization
in or out.
Currently the equalization
is out.
Let's put the equalization in.
We won't hear any effect from
that, because the gain
controls are all set at 0 dB.
And I'll want to illustrate
shortly the effect of these.
But before I do, let me draw
your attention to one other
filter, which is this
white switch.
And this switch is a highpass
filter that essentially cuts
out frequencies below
about 100 cycles.
So what it means is that if I
put this switch in, everything
is more or less flat
above 100 cycles.
And what that's used for,
basically, is to eliminate
perhaps 60 cycle noise, if
that's present, or some low
frequency hum or whatever.
Well, we won't really
demonstrate
anything with that.
Let's [? go ?] now with the
equalization in, demonstrate
the effect of boosting or
attenuating the low and high
frequencies.
And again, I think to
demonstrate this, it
illustrates the point the
best if we have a
little background music.
So maestro, if you can
bring that up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And so now what I'm going to
do is first boost the low
frequencies.
And that's what this
potentiometer knob will do.
So now, increasing the low
frequency gain and, in fact,
all the way up to 12 dB when I
have the knob over as far as
I've gone here.
And so that has a very
bassy sound.
And in fact, we can make it
even bassier by taking the
high frequencies and attenuating
those by 12 dB.
OK well, let's put some of the
high frequencies back in.
And now let's turn the
low-frequency gain first
back down to 0.
And now we're back to
flat equalization.
And now I can turn the low
frequency gain down so that I
attenuate the low frequencies
by much as 12 dB.
And that's where we are now.
And so this has, of course,
a much crisper sound.
And to enhance the highs even
more, I can, in addition to
cutting out the lows, boost
the highs by putting in,
again, as much as 12 dB.
OK well, let's turn down the
music now and go back to no
equalization by setting
these knobs to 0 dB.
And in fact, we can take
the equalizer out.
Well, that's a quick look at
some real-world filters.
Now let's stop having so
much fun, and let's
go back to the lecture.
OK well, that's a little
behind-the-scenes look.
What I'd like to do now is
turn our attention to
discrete-time filters.
And as I've meant in previous
lectures, there are basically
two classes of discrete-time
filters or discrete-time
difference equations.
One class is referred to a
non-recursive or moving
average filter.
And the basic idea with a
moving average filter is
something that perhaps you're
somewhat familiar with
intuitively.
Think of the notion of taking
a data sequence, and let's
suppose that what we wanted to
do was apply some smoothing to
the data sequence.
We could, for example, think
of taking adjacent points,
averaging them together, and
then moving that average along
the data sequence.
And what you can kind of see
intuitively is that that would
apply some smoothing.
So in fact, the difference
equation, let's say, for
three-point moving average
would be the difference
equation that I indicate here,
just simply taking a data
point and the two data points
adjacent to it and forming an
average of those three.
So if we thought of the
processing involved, if we're
forming an output sequence
value, we would take three
adjacent points and
average them.
That would give us the output
add the associated time.
And then to compute the next
output point, we would just
simply slide this by one point,
average these together,
and that would give us the
next output point.
And we would continue along,
just simply sliding and
averaging to form the output
data sequence.
Now, that's an example of what's
commonly referred to a
three-point moving average.
In fact, we can generalize
that notion
in a number of ways.
One way of generalizing the
notion of a moving average
from the three-point moving
average, which I summarize
again here, is to think of
extending that to a larger
number of points, and in fact
applying weights to that as I
indicated here, so that, in
addition to just summing up
the points and dividing by the
number of points summed, we
can, in fact, apply individual
weights to the points so that
it's what is often referred to
as a weighting moving average.
And I show below one possible
curve that might result, where
these would be essentially the
weights associated with this
weighted moving average.
And in fact, it's easy to
verify that this indeed
corresponds to the impulse
response of the filter.
Well, just to cement this
notion, let me show you an
example or two.
Here is an example of a
five-point moving average.
A five-point moving average
would have an impulse response
that just consists of a
rectangle of length five.
And if this is convolved with
a data sequence, that would
correspond to taking five
adjacent points and, in
effect, averaging them.
We've looked previously at the
Fourier transform of this
rectangular sequence.
And the Fourier transform of
that, in fact, is of the form
of a sine n x over
sine x curve.
And as you can see, that is
some approximation to a
lowpass filter.
And so this, again, is the
impulse response and frequency
response of a nonideal
lowpass filter.
Now, there are a variety of
algorithms that, in fact, tell
you how to choose the weights
associated with a weighted
moving average to, in some
sense, design better
approximations and without going
into the details of any
of those algorithms.
Let me just show the result of
choosing the weights for the
design of a 251-point moving
average filter, where the
weights are chosen using an
optimum algorithm to generate
as sharp a cutoff as can
possibly be generated.
And so what I show here is the
frequency response of the
resulting filter on a
logarithmic amplitude scale
and a linear frequency scale.
Notice that on this scale, the
passband is very flat.
Although here is an expanded
view of it.
And in fact, it has what's
referred to as an equal-ripple
characteristic.
And then here is the
transition band.
And here we have to stopband,
which in fact is down somewhat
more than 80 dB and, again, has
what's referred to as an
equal-ripple characteristic.
Now, the notion of a moving
average for filtering is
something that is very
commonly used.
I had shown last time actually
the result of some filtering
on a particular data
sequence, the Dow
Jones Industrial Average.
And very often, in looking at
various kinds of stock market
publications, what you will see
is the Dow Jones average
shown in its raw form
as a data sequence.
And then very typically, you'll
see also the result of
a moving average, where the
moving average might be on the
order of day, or it might be
on the order of months.
The whole notion being to take
some of the random high
frequency fluctuations out of
the average and show the low
frequency, or trends, over
some period of time.
So let's, in fact, go back
to the Dow Jones average.
And let me now show you what the
result of filtering with a
moving average filter would
look like on the same Dow
Jones industrial average
sequence that
I showed last time.
So once again, we have the Dow
Jones average from 1927 to
roughly 1932.
At the top, we see the
impulse response
for the moving average.
Again, I remind you on an
expanded time scale, and
what's shown here is
the moving average
with just one point.
So the output on the bottom
trace is just simply identical
to the input.
Now, let's increase the
length of the moving
average to two points.
And we see that there is a small
amount of smoothing,
three points and just
a little more
smoothing, that gets inserted.
Now a four-point moving
average, and next the
five-point moving average,
and a six-point
moving average next.
And we see that the smoothing
increases.
Now, let's increase the length
of the moving average filter
much more rapidly and watch
how the output is more and
more smooth in relation
to the input.
Again, I emphasize that the
time scale for the impulse
response is significantly
expanded in relationship to
the time scale for both the
input and the output.
And once again, through the
magic of filtering, we've been
able to eliminate the 1929
Stock Market Crash.
All right, so we've seen moving
average filters, or
what are sometimes referred to
as non-recursive filters.
And they are, as I stressed,
a very important class of
discrete-time filters.
Another very important class of
discrete-time filters are
what are referred to as
recursive filters.
Recursive filters are filters
for which the difference
equation has feedback from the
output back into the input.
In other words, the output
depends not only on the input,
but also on previous values
of the output.
So for example, as I've
stressed previously, a
recursive difference equation
has the general form that I
indicate here, a linear
combination of weighted
outputs on the left-hand side
and linear combination of
weighted inputs on the
right-hand side.
And as we've talked about, we
can solve this equation for
the current output y of n in
terms of current and past
inputs and past outputs.
For example, just to interpret
this, focus on the
interpretation of this as a
filter, let's look at a first
order difference equation, which
we've talked about and
generated the solution
to previously.
So the first order difference
equation would be as I
indicated here.
And imposing causality on this,
so that we assume that
we are running this as a
recursive forward in time, we
can solve this for y of n in
terms of x of n and y of n
minus 1 weighted by
the factor a.
And I simply indicate the
block diagram for this.
But what we want to examine
now for this first order
recursion is the frequency
response and see its
interpretation as a filter.
Well in fact, again, the
mathematics for this we've
gone through in the
last lecture.
And so interpreting the first
order difference equation as a
system, what we're attempting
to generate is the frequency
response, which is the
Fourier transform
of the impulse response.
And from the difference
equation, we can, of course,
solve for either one of those
by using the properties,
exploiting the properties,
of Fourier transform.
Applying the Fourier transform
to the difference equation, we
will end up with the Fourier
transform of the output equal
to the Fourier transform of the
input times this factor,
which we know from the
convolution property, in fact,
is the frequency response
of the system.
So this is the frequency
response.
And of course, the inverse
Fourier transform of that,
which I indicate below, is the
system impulse response.
So we have the frequency
response obtained by applying
the Fourier transform to the
difference equation, the
impulse response.
And, as we did last time, we can
look at that in terms of a
frequency response
characteristic.
And recall that, depending on
whether the factor a is
positive or negative, we either
get a lowpass filter or
a highpass filter.
And if, in fact, we look at the
frequency response for the
factor a being positive, then
we see that this is an
approximation to a lowpass
filter, whereas below it I
show the frequency response
for a negative.
And there this corresponds to
a highpass filter, because
we're attenuating low
frequencies and retaining the
high frequencies.
And recall also that
we illustrated this
characteristic as a lowpass or
highpass filter for the first
order recursion by looking at
how it worked as a filter in
both cases when the input was
the Dow Jones average.
And indeed, we saw that it
generated both lowpass and
highpass filtering in the
appropriate cases.
So for discrete-time, we have
the two classes, moving
average and recursive filters.
And there are a variety of
issues discussed in the text
about why, in certain contexts,
one might want to
use one of the other.
Basically, what happens is that
for the moving average
filter, for a given set a filter
specifications, there
are many more multiplications
required than
for a recursive filter.
But there are, in certain
contexts, some very important
compensating benefits for the
moving average filter.
Now, this concludes, pretty
much, what I want to say in
detail about filtering, the
concept of filtering, in the
set of lectures.
This is only a very quick
glimpse into a very important
and very rich topic, and one, of
course, that can be studied
on its own in an considerable
amount of detail.
As the lectures go on, what
we'll find is that the basic
concept of filtering, both ideal
and nonideal filtering,
will be a very important
part of what we do.
And in particular, beginning
with the next lecture, we'll
turn to a discussion of
modulation, exploiting the
property of modulation
as it relates to
some practical problems.
And what we'll find when we do
that is that a very important
part of that discussion and, in
fact, a very important part
of the use of modulation also
just naturally incorporates
the concept and properties
of filtering.
Thank you.